it's a great honor to be here tonight
and uh
great honor to
um
present the
five actresses in this next category
who've built their careers around the
most
um memorable and most unexpected
performances
in movie after movie
after movie
and
those actresses tonight we
recognized knight are the just the
latest example
of why they are considered
some of the most formidable
to ever grace the screen
and here are the nominees for
performance
by an actress in the leading role
jessica chastain the eyes of tammy faye
olivia coleman the lost daughter
penelope cruz parallel mothers
nicole kidman being the ricardo's
kristen stewart spencer
and the oscar goes to
jessica chastain
this is the first oscar and third
nomination for jessica chastain
thank you
thank you oh my gosh you guys
okay
all right
so
wow thank you so much to the
academy for this um
i definitely would not be up here right
now i probably wouldn't even have a
career if it wasn't for hildequiely paul
nelson steve warren and nicole perna
i love you guys thank you very much
i just have to say your guys's names
because i love you kristen nicole
penelope
uh olivia olivia i love you guys so much
and to be included in the conversation
with you is such an honor
uh
i have to thank um michael showalter my
director who created a space
that inspired creativity
and love and courage
um and the incredible hair makeup team
linda stephanie justin
who really helped me find her
uh producers kelly carmichael rachel
shane gigi pritzker i have to thank
david greenbaum matthew greenfield all
of searchlight for shepherding our film
my team partner
and collaborator andrew garfield the
brilliant edward garfield
thank you so much for bringing out the
best in me by showing up every day with
the best of you thank you
and uh
right now we are coming out of some
difficult times that have been filled
with a lot of trauma and isolation
and so many people out there
feel hopelessness and they feel alone
and
suicide is
a leading cause of death in the united
states it's touched many families it's
touched mine
and especially members of the lgbtq
community
who often times feel out of place with
their peers
there is
we're faced with
discriminatory
and bigoted legislation
that is sweeping our country
with the only goal of further dividing
us
there's violence
and hate crimes being perpetuated on
innocent civilians all over the world
and in times like this i think of tammy
and i'm inspired by her radical acts of
love we've talked about love a lot
tonight and i'm inspired by her
compassion i see it as a guiding
principle that leads us forward
and it connects us all
in the desire that we want to be
accepted for who we
are accepted for who we love
and to live a life
without the fear of violence or terror
and
for any of you
out there who do in fact feel
hopeless or alone i just want you to
know
that you are unconditionally loved
for the uniqueness that is you
and me
[Applause]
augustus
you are my heart
and i thank you all very very much thank
you
[Music]
you